[Music]
everyone and welcome to the data for
good session on driving social and
environmental impact with data analytics
my name is Elise Roche and I lead our
initiatives around data for social and
environmental impact here at Google
cloud thanks Elise thanks everyone for
being here I'm alone sorties the
Community Engagement Manager for the
global partnership for sustainable
development data the global partnership
is a network community to ensure we have
the necessary data to achieve the SDGs
and what we're really looking forward to
discussing here today are the
opportunities to apply data analytics
and machine learning to a variety of
issues and to solving some of the
world's greatest challenges in addition
to that also speaking to some of the use
cases that we're currently seeing with
nonprofits who are using our solutions
and also an initiative that we
collaborated on together around data
visualization so with that before
digging a little bit deeper into what
Google cloud is doing in this space and
what the global partnership team is
doing in this space wanted to look at
data for good as a concept as a movement
and discuss how it has evolved over time
so data for good is an international
movement where private companies are
working with governmental agencies NGOs
and nonprofits to apply big data
solutions to some of the world's
greatest challenges and dating back to
example four into 2008 the CDC
collaborate with Google to launch Google
Flu Trends with this idea that you could
actually look at search trends around
flu symptoms or similar searches to
actually help kind of predict outbreaks
in that area in 2011 the United Nations
global pulse organization advocated for
this idea of data philanthropy where
organizations that have access to data
can help make it available for public
benefit in 2013 the United Nations also
utilized satellite imagery to provide
targeted disaster relief looking at pre
disaster and post disaster areas in
order to determine which areas
communities etc needed the most support
as soon as possible later in 2017 the UN
hosted the world's first
Datta forum the second of which actually
took place in 2018 bringing together a
variety of different industries to
discuss again how we can all better work
together across the private and public
sectors in order to apply data analytics
to these challenging issues and here we
are in 2018 looking at interdisciplinary
programs in collaboration and with that
there's the question so what exactly is
Google cloud doing in this space so
Google cloud here we are working to
empower nonprofits with integrated
solutions from geospatial analysis tools
to productivity tools to even a
nonprofit grant program in 2007 Google
Maps helped nonprofits access satellite
imagery and api's with Google Earth
outreach in 2011 G suite for nonprofits
launched with the idea of enabling
nonprofits to collaborate and innovate
together it's also worth noting that
those two offerings are currently
available through the Google for
nonprofits website and platform in 2016
we launched GCP public datasets with
this idea of democratizing access to
planetary scale datasets that are freely
hosted in the cloud so whether you're a
nonprofit organization or not really any
GCP user can access these public
datasets and analyze them up to one
terabyte per month at no charge and
these include datasets from
organizations like the EPA the US
Department of Health and Human Services
the World Bank the United Nations
statistics division the list continues
and in 2018 we actually announced the
Data Solutions for change program which
is a nonprofit grant program with the
goal of empowering nonprofits to achieve
their missions at scale with data
analytics essentially we understand that
with big data solutions nonprofits can
scale their data they can analyze data
at the scale of the entire web with
bigquery they can automate their work
and tap into artificial intelligence
with cloud machine learning and they can
also share their vision and turn their
data into customizable reports with
tools like Google Data studio and that's
essentially what underscores the data
Solutions for change program where we're
looking to address too
challenges that nonprofits often face
when trying to access data analytics and
data analytics solutions one being
financial and the other technical so
with the data solutions for Change
Program what we're offering includes
Google cloud credits a need-based Google
cloud credit grant depending on their
proposal self training resources through
quick labs and also hands-on support
through Google cloud customer support
for the duration of their six-month
grant period and while this program just
launched in 2018 we're already seeing a
variety of nonprofits applying these
solutions in really interesting ways one
of them is the open agriculture
foundation where they're using bigquery
and IOT core in order to create
healthier more engaging and more
inventive food with technology they've
actually developed these proprietary
food computers where they're looking to
essentially develop plant codes plant
recipe codes and looking at different
variables so that they can understand
for example how a basil plant responds
to a certain humidity level versus
lettuce
Harambee youth employment accelerator is
a nonprofit organization based in South
Africa
they're using bigquery and machine
learning to connect more unemployed
youth in South Africa with jobs they
understand that the public
transportation system in South Africa
can be particularly challenging and so
with entry-level applicants they're
looking at developing a proprietary
machine learning algorithm and a job
matching algorithm so that they're not
only matching these entry-level
applicants with new positions but also
working towards job retention it's also
worth noting that they recently received
a school social entrepreneurship award
this year the foundation for precision
medicine is using bigquery and machine
learning to detect Alzheimer's disease
early with the goal of stopping the
progression of the disease
so with Alzheimers in particular there's
currently not a cure today and so a lot
of research is focused around finding
that cure but what the foundation for
precision medicine is doing is they're
actually taking a bit of a different
approach they have this idea of
essentially getting ahead of a diagnosis
a traditional diagnosis by months or
even years so as to prescribe
preventative treatment
power poetry a bit of a shift towards
the arts what they're doing is they're
using machine learning to increase teen
literacy through interactive
recommendation engines they've created
their own proprietary machine learning
algorithms to match teen submissions
teen poetry submissions with rap artists
and American poets
Brewed minder is also another
organization working with our technology
and what they're doing is they're using
firebase and cloud firestore to manage
their IOT beehive tracking sensors and
to improve bee health around the u.s. so
for those unfamiliar with kind of the
state of the bee population today it is
declining their health is declining
they're facing hive collapse around the
United States and this is concerning not
only to the bee populations and
biodiversity more broadly but also given
the impact that that may have upon our
food systems given the importance of
pollinators
especially around fruits and vegetables
and one more example to share with you
all is around biodiversity so the
Zoological Society of London is using
Auto amount to optimize camera trap
surveys and to advance research studies
but that ultimate goal of preserving
biodiversity camera-trap surveys are an
extremely popular method of research in
this space and they use motion sensors
oftentimes these sensors can have you
know false positives so that what you
will you end up with after these surveys
are thousands upon thousands of images
that need to be manually analyzed as you
can imagine that's extremely time
consuming so you end up having folks
with PhDs in biology going through each
of these camera trap images individually
over a period of months and what they're
working towards is reducing that time of
analysis from months to just days and
I'd like to share a video that tells a
little bit more about zsl and their
journey
the main challenges facing wildlife
today is how to at loss climate change
and threats from the illegal wildlife
trade so sales mission is to create a
world where wildlife thrives we work in
over 50 countries around the world where
we empower and inform people to help
stop we have been working with Google to
look at how we can use cloud or Terminal
to really make a difference we use
camera traps to monitor the state of the
planet they are tiny little digital
cameras hooked up to a little motion
sensor basically so when an animal walks
past the photo which you can then
retrieve at a time as well as telling
you about how abundant different species
are it can also offer behavioral
insights as well
one camera trap study generates hundreds
and thousands of images so over six
months you might get half a million
images that you need to sort through and
analyze you've got to go for every
single image you've got to label them
the time the date what it contained
which camera was at the moment it takes
once if we can speed up the analysis
from six months to just days that's
revolutionary in our conservation
efforts Google plan or terminal allows
conservationists who are non coders use
machine learning to create image
recognition models to identify species
in camera trap images these are images
that I have labeled and they're going to
the auto ml algorithm what different
species look like if you can just alter
our managed you could go
show me the images of that empty showing
the images that have the animal I'm
interested in Russia use of scientific
who's such a conservation time to do
conservation rather than doing danger
analysis we might use the data to
actually influence policy change or
conservation action AI is going to play
a really big part in collecting all the
data together from wildlife conservation
sites around the world and if we do that
in real time we can use autumn amounts
really monitor the possible life across
the planet
[Music]
[Applause]
so from before I talk about the work we
do at the global partnership for
sustainable development data I want to
talk about the 17 sustainable
development goals what you're seeing in
this light is the result of years of
negotiations between 193 countries they
were agreed in 2015 and they are to be
met in 2030 they are a framework or a
guide to take action towards reducing
poverty protecting the planet ensuring
prosperous societies and I want to
highlight four key things about the SDGs
first the fact that 193 countries agreed
to something especially such an
inspirational framework successful in
and of itself especially because they
have been a widely a able to capture
attention from citizens civil society
and companies so the second aspect that
I want to highlight is their
universality they're not only to be
implemented by governments but also by
other stakeholders and thankfully many
have a committed to achieving them and
are adapting and adopting them whether a
from civil society or from the private
sector and they're contributing to them
and I also want to highlight that
they're not only to be implemented in
developing countries but also in
developments the third thing I want to
highlight is the even though we're
seeing individual goals they're all
connected to each other in order to
achieve long lasting change we need to
tackle all of them at the same time for
example as dg2 and in conger is
connected to SDG 16 and as DG 15 so when
thinking about ending hunger we need to
think of land rights and protecting the
environment so they are connected to
each other and finally
the architects of the SDGs besides
giving us the goals they also left us
with 169 targets and 233 indicators to
accompany the agenda and the targets can
be thought of the objectives and the
policies they need to be put in place
and the indicators are the way we
measure progress along the way and
ultimately if we achieve impact so
however there's a big a missing piece in
this puzzle and that data data is the
lifeblood of sustainable development and
in this case the responsibility falls
mainly in governments who are mandated
to official report on the SDGs and as we
know governments have a hard time to
produce timely or real-time data in many
cases governments are taking decisions
with all data or in some cases in the
case of countries afflicted by a
conflict there's no data at all so
that's where the work of the global
partnership comes in so we're a global
network committed to ensure we have the
necessary data to achieve and monitor
the stds we're founded in 2015 alongside
the sustainable development goals and we
bring together government civil society
UN agencies multilaterals and the
private sector to collectively solve the
problems and gaps around the production
and use of data we don't collect or
provide the data ourselves with rather
provided strategic partnerships advocacy
technical assistance and pilot tests for
our partners at the national regional
and global level we also provide offline
and online spaces for partners to come
together and tackle specific challenges
for example we set up a SDG data
collaborative with UN statistics
division to work towards better
interoperability and we host
international events such as the data
for development festival finally all the
work that we do attempts to reduce the
barriers the technical barriers that
there are to have better data but also
the political ones
and for example a I want to talk about a
the Africa original dataq and so we're
supporting five countries in Eastern
West Africa to access and use 17 years
of satellite data in order to improve
their policymaking and we are connecting
them with key partners such as NASA and
the group on earth observations so they
can have analysis a ready data through
an infrastructure called a data cube the
data cube it has many applications
it helps us it helps governments
understand land degradation detect
illegal mining and strengthen food
security so about a decade ago a country
such as Kenya would have paid
approximately a million dollars per year
in order to access this data harbor it
is now open and free but the challenge
does not end with having data there are
many technical issues a whole
infrastructure that need to be set up in
order to collect a have the data and
analyze it and have the necessary
capacities to do so so by bringing
together these five countries through a
common infrastructure was helping them
to troubleshoot together to take
training together and as well to learn
from each other along the way and
especially having governments a at the
highest level agree and commit to this
infrastructure we're also putting the
right political attention so it has
resources and there's collaboration
between different agencies and
ministries and we are expanding
expanding this initiative to support
countries in Latin America and the
Caribbean and we're doing so with with
the help of Google cloud and some
credits that we're getting through their
Data Solutions for a change program and
in addition to that we have partnered a
for the last year with with Google cloud
to do a series of SDG related contests
in which we want to to get better ideas
and
and have attention and how to bring
solutions for the STDs thanks Alonso
so one of the SDG related contest that
Alonso just mentioned is visualized 2030
visualized 2030 data stories for the SD
G's is a data storytelling contest for
students where we ask students from
around the world to analyze data sets
from the World Bank and from the United
Nations statistics division to visualize
that data using Google Data studio and
to ultimately tell a data-driven story
about how at least two of the
sustainable development goals influenced
each other and how we can achieve them
by 2030 there's an interesting backstory
behind this contest as well so Alonso
mentioned the data for development
festival before and that was in part the
inspiration for the visualized 2030
contest at that festival there were a
lot of talks and sessions about the
importance of democratizing access to
data about inviting everyone to the
table and making this data accessible
and consumable by everyone and data
visualization has a big part to play in
that and that's essentially what led to
the ideation around this contest and
bringing it to life later that year in
2018 for the applicants the top five
eligible submissions were to receive a
$10,000 cash prize an announcement and
promotion by Google cloud we also were
working with the World Bank and also the
United Nations Foundation to make this
possible so again you know thinking
about what's at the heart of the global
partnership for sustainable development
data there's this idea of cooperation
and building bridges and this was
definitely also at the heart of this
contest we also worked with an expert
panel of judges in order to select the
final five winners including Rajesh
Mirchandani chief communications officer
of the United Nations Foundation Clare
Mohammed who's the CEO of the global
partnership team hi Shawn foo a director
at the World Bank Richard Curtis who is
a writer director and co-founder of the
Red Nose Day you also may be familiar
with some of his popular films like Love
Actually
Cindy housen who at the time was a
at Gartner Fausto Ibarra director of
product management with Google marketing
platform and Simon Rogers data editor at
the News lab at Google so with this
expert panel of judges we're really
looking to bring together a variety of
expertise areas together from
sustainable development to
communications to data storytelling in
order to assess the finalists and
determine again these these top five
winners so these are the five students
who submitted the most compelling SDG
data stories actually with all so we
have Evan Kelsey and Sarah could you
please raise your hands around the clock
please
so you come from different backgrounds
or specializing different topics and
some are doing undergraduate studies and
some are graduate students however
through storytelling and design they all
provided compelling ways in which and
stories to talk about the SDGs and
they're having their ideas could have
real-world impact and we hope they don't
stop here what stood out amongst all of
the submissions the the winning
submissions is that they also found
these relationships between how one go
affects the other and positive changes
in one lead to two benefits on others
and vice versa so Aneesa is a master
student of interactive journalism at
City University of London she focused on
SD g5 and SD g 16 which are gender
equality peace justice and strong
institutions respectively she explored
the relationship between increased
female participation and less corruption
and stronger institutions
she assumed in Rhonda's data as an
example of positive change
so Anna is a student at UC Berkeley's
master of information and data science
program she focused on sg3 as the g4s DG
5 and s DG 8 which are good health and
well-being quality education gender
equality decent work and economic growth
respectively she explored these
dimensions across a variety of
visualizations to make the case that
gender equality must be embedded in core
social structures to have impact and
that as a result other areas that rely
on these same structures will have
positive gains evan is a commerce
student at McMaster University he
focused on desta g1 no poverty and as DG
13 climate action he walked us through
the story of how as middle-income
countries begin to catch up with
high-income states the resources
consumption and co2 contributions
exponentially increase he used data to
back up his recommendations and provide
and provided useful ways to engage on
these issues so another one of the
finalists Kelsey Wang developed a data
story called the inequalities of today
and tomorrow where she focused on how
education can help to address both
poverty and climate change
looking at SDGs one 4 and 13
she began her data story with a question
are people doing better or worse than
before how can we compare the past to
the present a very loaded question of
course but from there she dug deeper
into the expansion of the human
population which as of 2017 is over 7
billion people and also changes in life
expectancy and looking at those two
variables to think about the unintended
kind of consequences that come from that
for example agricultural industrial
agriculture and land scarcity as well
especially with increases in income
inequality Kelsey made the case at
education and internet technologies can
actually
act as an equaliser across the world and
also serve to empower individuals around
how they can take action around climate
change at the end of her story kelsey
concluded that quality education for
everyone is a building block for a
better more sustainable and more
equitable future Sarah Liu in her data
story titled earth water air and rising
temperatures focused on a total of four
SDG so not just two but four
specifically seg2 on zero hunger SDG six
clean water and sanitation SDG 13 around
climate action and SDG 15 life on land
so as you can see a pictured here sarah
developed an interactive roadmap to
sustainable development so really
analyzing the effects that agriculture
has upon the environment from land-use
to water scarcity she assessed
agricultural greenhouse gas emissions
over time changes in land use and also
livestock waste management so really
looking at these variables holistically
in addition she presented a case study
on Madagascar land use and how nearly
800 mammal species are threatened by
agriculture and habitat loss today
another case study explored this data
story are explored in this data story
was that of Ethiopia where in 2016 over
90 percent of available fresh water was
used for agricultural purposes
overall Sarah made the case for
sustainable agriculture as key to
combating climate change fostering life
on land providing clean water and
sanitation to everyone and concluded
with a call to action for everyone to
practice more sustainable habits
including limiting meat consumption and
supporting urban farming so with that we
would like to say you know there's an
opportunity to learn more about our
respective organizations and these
initiatives starting with the global
partnership for sustainable development
data so we're an organization based
network so if you're interested in
becoming part of us all the information
is available on our website I would also
want to invite you to check out our
Twitter account data for SDGs and to
subscribe to our newsletter we really
strive to provide
interesting information and ways to
engage not only with the partnership but
also with the whole network and for more
information on data solutions for change
including the non profit stories and
just exciting information around you
know how if you're a non-profit how you
can access this program how you can
apply you can visit cloud cuckoo com
slash Data Solutions for change pictured
here and also to learn more about
visualize 2030 and the winners
themselves and you can also explore
their interactive data to data stories
within the Google data studio tool you
can visit cloud kugel comm slash
visualize 2030 and again just another
note to kind of wrap this session before
we open to questions and very much
encouraging questions is that what is
key across all these initiatives and
what we've discussed today again is this
this idea of cooperation of looking
across industries and really looking at
what can everyone bring to the table in
these initiatives there are experts
across a variety of different areas
whether that's you know biodiversity or
food systems or you know even students
working around data visualization and
data analysis and you know working you
know together and making these
opportunities available we can
accomplish some pretty exciting things
and work towards addressing some of the
world's greatest challenges
[Music]